jeepney means pick me up in the libyan
dialect it's a ride hailing company
recently launched it by two Libyan
entrepreneurs with a mobile phone app
and Facebook page jeepney offers rides
for people mostly in the capital Tripoli
technology which figures out driving
growth for drivers and calculates the
distance and fare is something new in
Libya we did our soft launch for the
application in March one month before
the attack on Tripoli after about a
month when everything happened we saw
significant drop in our numbers we were
a bit worried about that but luckily
that didn't continue this company
provides work space for students and
business owners who can't find it in
their own areas with frequent power and
internet cuts in many parts of the city
especially in the areas affected by the
fighting it also provides a safe place
for customers we find a good market I
mean there are many people like it there
is a good demand for it and you know for
any business if you have a would demand
then then you are okay the conflict in
Libya has forced many young people to
seek new careers abroad but despite the
challenges in the country some are still
enthusiastic about creating their own
businesses and bringing new ideas to the
market but many here say they're worried
what will happen if the fighting in
southern Tripoli moves a closer to the
city centre many businesses have been
shut down since the warlord Khalifa
Haftar launched it his military campaign
to seize Tripoli from the
internationally recognized the
government in April official figures
suggest the war has cost the economy
more than forty billion dollars that
includes losses caused by the blockade
of the oil facilities by forces loyal to
heffter these entrepreneurs say their
businesses should be able
to withstand the declining state
revenues there are now hoping the
fighting will in to allow their
businesses to grow even further but if
the battle for Tripoli continues these
young Libyans are unlikely to have many
free spaces like these who Dubois hate
al Jazeera Tripoli